foreign
[Music]
well uh please if you have a seat please
take it
it's an honor honor to be here to
welcome prime minister Albanese and
prime minister sunac
and it's my honor to welcome both to the
United States
as we take the next critical step
in advancing the Australia U.S UK
partnership August
it's an unusual name Marcus but it's a
powerful entity
you know when our country's first
announced August 18 months ago I'm not
at all sure that anyone believed that
how much progress you'd be able to make
together and how quickly we'd accomplish
it
and I want to thank the members of all
of our teams who helped bring us to this
pivotal moment sitting in front of us
thank you all very much secretary Austin
Secretary of the Navy del Toro
thanks for letting us come to your house
[Applause]
and uh and thank you for hosting us at
the naval base of Point Loma and I also
want to thank representative Joe
Courtney founder of the bipartisan
office working group and all the members
of the Congress who are here today thank
you for being here you are
Testament to the strong and and deep
support for this partnership across the
United States
Australian United Kingdom are of two of
America's most stalwart and capable
allies our common values our shared
Vision more peaceful and prosperous
future unite us all across the Atlantic
and Pacific for more than a century
we've stood together to defend freedom
and strengthen democracy
year and despair greater opportunity in
all our countries
I've always said
when I asked the United States as a
Pacific Power because we're on the
Pacific Ocean we are Pacific Power the
United States has safeguarded stability
in indo-pacific for decades through the
enormous benefits of Nations throughout
the region from asean to Pacific
Islanders to the People's Republic of
China
in fact our leadership in the Pacific
has been the benefit to the entire world
we've kept the sea lanes and Skies open
and navigable for all
we've upheld basic rules of the road
fueled International Commerce
and our Partnerships have helped
underwrite incredible growth and
Innovation so today
as we stand at the inflection point of
History where the hard work of enhancing
deterrence and promoting stability is
going to affect the prospect of Peace
for decades to come the United States
can ask for no better partners in the
indo-pacific where so much of our shared
future will be written
forging this new partnership we're
showing again how democracies can
deliver our own security and prosperity
and not just for us but for the entire
world
today we're announcing the steps to
carry out our first project under August
and developing Australia's
conventionally armed nuclear-powered
submarine capacity and I want to be
clear I want to be clear to everyone
from the outset
right off the bat so there's no
confusion or misunderstanding in this
critical point these Subs are powered
not nuclear armed substance or nuclear
powered not nuclear armed Australia is a
proud non-nuclear weapon state and is
committed to stay that way
these boats will not have any nuclear
weapons of any kind on them each of us
standing here today representing the
United States Australia and Great
Britain is deeply committed to
strengthening the nuclear
non-proliferation regime
we've undertaken this project working
hand and glove with International atomic
energy agency and with director General
Grossi Australia will not produce
nuclear fuel needed for these submarines
we have set the highest standards with
the iaea for verification and
transparency and we will honor each of
our country's International obligations
working together
these past 18 months
developed a phased approach that's going
to make sure our Australian Sailors are
fully trained and prepared to safely
operate this Fleet so they can deliver
this critical new capacity
a fastest fastest possible timetable
each of our Nations
is making concrete commitments to one
another
we're backing it up with significant
Investments to strengthen the industrial
bases in each of our countries in order
to build and support these boats by the
way this partnership is going to mean an
awful lot for good paying jobs for all
workers in our countries including a lot
of union jobs
there's reason why not everyone has
nuclear-powered submarines
nuclear propulsion is a highly
complicated technology that requires
years of training to master
so we're starting right away
beginning this year Australian personnel
will embed with U.S and UK Crews on
boats and the bases in our schools and
our shipyards will also begin to
increase our Port visits to Australia
in fact as we speak the nuclear-powered
sub USS Asheville is making a port call
in Perth as we speak
and later this decade we'll also be
established in a rotational presence of
U.S and UK nuclear-powered Subs in
Australia to help develop the workforce
Australia is going to need to build and
maintain its Fleet
one of the vessels you see behind me the
Virginia class nuclear-powered submarine
the USS Missouri
top of the line submarines are the
Vanguard of U.S naval power
and excuse me for our point of personal
privilege as they say in the United
States Senate where I've spent a lot of
time
these submarines hold a special place
for the bidens
my wife Dr Jill Biden is a sponsor of
the USS Delaware a virginia-class
submarine and she never lets me forget
it
they feature Cutting Edge propulsive
technology provide unmatched stealth and
maneuverability
with the support and approval of
Congress beginning in the early 2030s
the United States will sell three
virginia-class submarines in Australia
with the potential to sell up to two
more if needed jump starting their
undersea capability and decade earlier
than many predicted but the ultimate
goal isn't just selling Subs in
Australia it's developing something new
together
we're calling it the SSN August
this new state-of-the-art conventionally
armed nuclear-powered submarine
that will work that will combine U.S
summary or UK submarine technology and
design with American Technology
and I want to reiterate again the SSN
not August will not have nuclear weapons
it'll become a future standard for both
the UK Royal Navy and the Royal
Australian Navy it'll meet Australia's
defense needs while bringing our
militaries our scientists our Engineers
our ship Builders our industrial
Workforce our countries closer together
closer than ever
let me emphasize again
nuclear propulsion
tested and safe
the United States and the UK have used
it for nearly 70 years
from with spotless record a spotless
record
combined between U.S and UK all of our
nuclear powered ships have traveled the
entire globe
around the entire globe more than
150 million miles
that's gone on the moon 300 times
we can't figure out how to get this sub
to the moon but we're working on it and
I've got to admit our stewardship of
Naval nuclear propulsion technology is a
point of Honor pride and deep tradition
currently held by Admiral Frank Caldwell
who is here today where are you Admiral
thank you
in the years of training for undertaking
starting now will ensure that Australia
is fully prepared to carry on this
tradition and meet the highest possible
standards of safety throughout the life
of these boats
are unprecedented trilateral cooperation
I believe is Testament to the strength
of the long-standing ties of Uniteds
and to our shared commitment of ensuring
The indo-pacific Remains free and open
prosperous and secure
to find the opportunity for all a shared
commitment to create a future rooted in
our common values
that's the objective the United States
shares not only with the UK and
Australia it's shared by our friends in
the region by our friends in asean the
Pacific island form of the quad and
other treaty and close Partners in the
inner Pacific and Europe
August has won overriding objective to
enhance the stability of indo-pacific
amid rapidly shifting Global Dynamics
in this first project
this first project is only beginning
more Partnerships more potential more
peace and Security in the region lies
ahead simply stated we're putting
ourselves in the strongest possible
position
to navigate the challenges of today and
tomorrow together
together
so I thank you again prime minister
Albanese Mr Prime Minister sunak
and the United States could not ask for
two better friends or Partners to stand
with as we work to create a safer more
peaceful future for the people
everywhere
I'm proud to be your Shipmates thank you
well President Biden prime minister
sunac I am so honored to stand alongside
you both
here overlooking the Pacific Ocean as
Leaders of true and trusted friends of
my country of Australia
today a new chapter in the relationship
between our nation the United States and
the United Kingdom begins
a friendship built on our shared values
our commitment to democracy and our
common vision for a peaceful and a
prosperous future
the orcus agreement we confirm here in
San Diego
represents the biggest single investment
in Australia's defense capability in all
of our history
strengthening Australia's national
security and stability in our region
building a future made in Australia with
record investments in skills jobs and
infrastructure and delivering a superior
defense capability into the future
my government is determined to invest in
our defense capability but we're also
determined to promote security by
investing in our relationships across
our region
from early in the next decade Australia
will take delivery of three U.S
virginia-class nuclear-powered
submarines
this is the first time in 65 years and
only the second time in history that the
United States has shared its nuclear
propulsion technology and we thank you
for it
we are also proud to partner with the
United Kingdom to construct the Next
Generation submarine to be called SSN
orcus
a new conventionally armed
nuclear-powered submarine based on a
British design and incorporating
cutting-edge Australian UK and U.S
Technologies
this will be an Australian Sovereign
capability
built by Australians commanded by the
Royal Australian Navy and sustained by
Australian workers in Australian
shipyards with construction to begin
this decade
Australia's proud record of leadership
in the international nuclear
non-proliferation regime will of course
continue
we will continue to adhere to all of our
obligations under the nuclear
non-proliferation treaty and the Treaty
of Rarotonga
our agreement unlocks a set of
transformative opportunities for jobs
and skills and research and innovation
in Adelaide and in Barrow in finesse in
Western Australia and here in the United
States
opportunities that will shape and
strengthen and grow Australia's economy
for decades and create around 20 000
direct jobs for Australians from many
trades and specializations
engineers
scientists technicians submariners
administrators And Trades people good
jobs with good wages working to ensure
the stability and prosperity of our
Nations our region and indeed our world
our future Security will be built and
maintained not just by the courage and
professionalism of our Defense Forces
but by the hard work and know-how of our
scientists and Engineers our technicians
and programmers our electricians and
welders
for Australia this whole of nation
effort also presents a whole of nation
opportunity we will work with the state
governments of South Australia and
Western Australia to develop training
programs that equip Australians with the
skills they need to fill these jobs
working together our universities and
research institutes will collaborate to
train more Australians in nuclear
engineering we're already sharing skills
and knowledge and expertise across our
borders lifting the capability and
capacity of all three countries
already today
Australians are upskilling on nuclear
technology and stewardship alongside
their British and American counterparts
already today there are Australian
submariners undergoing nuclear power
training in the United States and I'm
proud to confirm Mr President that they
are all in the top 30 of their class
built by Innovation and extraordinary
and emerging Technologies these boats
will present a unique opportunity for
Australian companies to contribute not
only to the construction of sustainment
of Australia's new submarines but to
supply chains in America and in Britain
the scale complexity and economic
significance of this investment is akin
to the creation of the Australian
automotive industry in the post-world
War II period and just as a vision of my
predecessors Curtin and chifley in
creating our automotive industry lifted
up our entire manufacturing sector this
investment will be a catalyst for
Innovation and research breakthroughs
that will reverberate right throughout
the Australian economy and across every
state and territory not just in one
design element not just in one field but
right across our Advanced manufacturing
and Technology sectors creating jobs and
growing businesses right around
Australia inspiring and rewarding
Innovation and educating young
Australians today for the opportunities
of tomorrow
our August partnership is not just about
the US and UK sharing their most
advanced submarine capability with
Australia although we do appreciate that
it's also about building on the
expertise within our three nations so
that we can achieve things greater than
the sum of our parts
this is a genuine trilateral undertaking
all three nations stand ready to
contribute and all three nations stand
ready to benefit
I look out from here today
and I see New Frontiers in Innovation to
cross new breakthroughs in technology to
achieve a new course for us to chart
together
Mr President prime minister
for more than a century our brave
citizens from our three countries have
been part of a shared tradition of
service in the cause of peace and
sacrifice in the name of freedom
we honor their memory today
we always will
while we respect and honor the past
through orcas we turn ourselves to face
the future
because what the United States the
United Kingdom and Australia hold in
common is more fundamental and more
Universal than our shared histories
we are bound Above All by our belief in
a world where the sovereignty of every
nation is respected and the inherent
Dignity of every individual is upheld
where peace stability and security
ensure greater prosperity and greater
measure of fairness for all and where
all countries are able to act in their
Sovereign interests free from coercion
our historic orcas partnership speaks to
our Collective and ongoing determination
to defend those values and secure that
future
today in the years ahead and for
generations to come a journey that will
strengthen the bonds between our Nations
as friends
as peers
as leaders
we Embark with great confidence in the
capacity and creativity of our people
with optimism in the power of what our
partnership can achieve and with an
unwavering conviction that whatever the
challenges ahead the cause of Peace and
Freedom that we share will prevail thank
you very much
[Applause]
60 years ago here in San Diego President
Kennedy
spoke of a higher purpose
the maintenance of Freedom peace and
security
Today We Stand Together United by that
same purpose
and recognizing that to fulfill it we
must Forge new kinds of relationships to
meet new kinds of challenge just as we
have always done
and the last 18 months the challenges we
Face have only grown
Russia's illegal invasion of Ukraine
China's growing assertiveness the
destabilizing behavior of Iran and North
Korea all threaten to create a world
defined by danger disorder and Division
faced with this new reality it is more
important than ever
that we strengthen the resilience of our
own countries
that's why the UK is today announcing a
significant uplift in our defense budget
we're providing an extra five billion
pounds over the next two years
immediately increasing our defense
budget to around 2.25 of GDP
this will allow us to replenish our war
stocks and modernize our nuclear
Enterprise delivering orcas and
strengthening our deterrent
and our highest priority
is to continue providing military aid to
Ukraine because their security is our
security
and we will go further to strengthen our
resilience
for the first time the United Kingdom
will move away from our Baseline
commitment to spend two percent of GDP
on defense to a new ambition of 2.5
percent
putting Beyond doubt that the United
Kingdom is and will remain one of the
world's leading defense powers
But ultimately the defense of our values
depends as it always has on the quality
of our relationships with others
and those alliances will be strengthened
through orcas the most significant
multilateral defense partnership in
Generations
orcas matches our enduring commitment to
freedom and democracy
with the most advanced military
scientific and technological capability
nowhere is that clearer than in the
plans we're unfailing today for the new
orcas submarine one of the most advanced
nuclear-powered Subs the world has ever
known
those plans
could not happen without cutting edge
American Technology and expertise so I
pay tribute to you Mr President for your
leadership
and to you prime minister for your
vision of what orcas can achieve
and for our part the UK comes to this
with over 60 years experience of running
our own Fleet we'll provide the
world-leading design and build the first
of these new boats creating thousands of
good well-paid jobs in places like
Barrow and Derby
and we will share our knowledge and
experience with Australian Engineers so
they can build their own Fleet
now our partnership is significant
because not just are we building these
submarines together they will also be
truly interoperable
the Royal Navy will operate the same
submarines as the Australian Navy and we
will both share components and parts
with the US Navy our submarine crews
will train together Patrol together and
maintain their boats together they will
communicate using the same terminology
and the same equipment
and through orcas we will raise our
standards of nuclear non-proliferation
this is a powerful partnership
for the first time ever it will mean
three fleets of submarines working
together across both the Atlantic and
Pacific keeping our oceans free open and
prosperous for decades to come
Joe Anthony
we represent three allies who have stood
shoulder to shoulder together for more
than a century
three peoples who have shed blood
together in defense of our shared values
and three democracies that are coming
together again
to fulfill that higher purpose of
maintaining Freedom peace and security
Now
and for generations to come thank you
the permission of my colleagues I know
what our friends can hear
but the USS Missouri can you hear us
I see them all over there
they're standing attention can I tell
them at ease I'm their
commander-in-chief right I mean
anyway thank you thank you thank you
thank you thank you you are the best
you're the best and we're going to be
the best in the world the three of us
thank you all very very much
[Applause]
[Music]